ce qu'on peut faire mal le regard de
l'autre ils tuent ils tuent les gens à
l'intérieur la grossophobie c'est une
discrimination ancien dans votre société
bien que moins étudiée que d'autres
longtemps l'image du bon vivant tout en
rondeur à prêter à sourire de la
moquerie quotidienne parfois innocente
pourtant plaissan exemple en 1965 avec
cet homme gros dans le passé tout le
monde disait voilà le gros party le
groupe par là et c'est très désagréable
pourquoi la rondeur attise temps de
réaction le professeur jean trémolières
l'un des fondateurs de la nutrition
moderne française tentait d'y répondre
en 1972 le signe d'une société puritaine
moralisatrice qui juge par le dehors et
non pas par l'âme et paix alors plus
profondément c'est le signe qu'on se
soucie de ce comparer quand on ne sait
pas ce qu'on est
la société du paraître les années 70
sont celles de l'injonction à la minceur
vanté par la publicité et même par des
journalistes de magazines féminins tous
les cas qui ne sont pas pathologique
c'est à dire tous les gens qui ne sont
pas malades doivent redevenir normaux
trente ans plus tard la norme ne veut
pas de rondeur même au travail
ce alors que depuis 2001 la loi interdit
la discrimination à l'embauché sur des
critères physiques
elle est malgré tout pratiquée selon une
étude de l'université du mirail en 2004
cette femme raconte comment elle a été
évincée d'un poste de serveuse
on m'a dit texto que comme on refuserait
le travail en salle lorsqu'il avait une
image de marque à respecter et que mon
physique ne convenait pas à cette image
de marque
le travail et le quotidien à voir ces
images de 2006 encore d'actualité la vie
n'est pas taillé à la mesure des gros la
personne obèse mise
ban de la société en 2006 le psychiatre
gérard apfeldorfer il voit la crainte
d'un effet miroir le reflet des excès de
la société de consommation chez l'obèse
la surconsommation elle se voit donc on
va lui jeter des pierres
et finalement si on si on est tellement
agressif vis-à-vis des obèses c'est
aussi parce qu'on a peur tous finalement
de perdre le contrôle
et finalement de devenir obèse nous
mêmes en france 17 % des adultes sont
obèses selon l'inserm
malgré les mouvements body positive en
faveur de la représentation des physique
rond aujourd'hui parmi les personnalités
médiatiques et artistique
le gros est encore marginale
[Musique]